um so dude there was a story that we
heard about uh
you saved his life yeah you saved my
life
this was uh maybe you at least saved me
from getting my ass beat maybe could
have been
because back in the day like way back in
the day um
like 2003 2004
um i had been disrespectful
uh to the insane clown posse there was
something like they
they i was trying to say they're not
real clowns because i had gone to clown
college whatever i was just out of my
mind on drugs just being a dick wad
and uh
talking about like oh man like you can
come on stage but they weren't wearing
their makeup they don't want to appear
without their makeup on right right
right like ah these guys
they won't come on stage or whatever i
was just being a dick and so they
decided that the next time they saw me
they were gonna [ __ ] beat my ass try
to jack you up they were gonna they were
gonna give me a thumpin and uh and and
they showed up at the rainbow and said
there he is all right man there we go
and then they started sitting with you
and they were like oh [ __ ] we can't do
that be real is our boy yeah we go back
and uh
we've done many shows with them and
many you know
different sorts of conversations that
have happened you know the history of of
cyprusil and icp
and so you know you know there's a
mutual respect there so they saw you
sitting there with me and they were like
no no we're not going to do that yeah i
did i love those guys now man i mean i'm
full on hatchet man tattoo too hey man
when we're young and on one man it just
doesn't matter like we don't think about
[ __ ] we're just
going and doing it we don't give a [ __ ]
who we offend or if somebody gets
defensive or whatever you know i mean
it's we're just going
and then we realized later oh [ __ ] maybe
we're really dickish right now for
and i think that like whenever like
whenever you pop off in some kind of uh
you know
celebrity way i think there's growing
pains involved you know like you can't
you can't go from like nobody knows you
and then everybody knows you and not
like
have some kind of like acting out like
yeah there's there's
for for for what we do right so like hip
hop music and for the land that you came
from there is no school for it yeah it's
all learning it as you go along there
you know there's no guides there's no
teachers to tell you this is the way you
should be going don't [ __ ] around over
here
and
you know it's it's those growing pains
those bumps in the roads and
fortunately for us
you know we've managed to go through all
those bumps in the roads and all that
[ __ ] and still be here it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude